let's talk about filling the swamp oh
I'm sorry it's supposed to be draining
the swamp but it's actually getting
filled not drained contrary to what
Donald Trump promise time and again
during his campaign he continues to fill
the swamp Trump is filling top positions
at the department of defense Homeland
Security and the State Department with
defense contractors and their lobbyists
people from companies who are paid to
manufacture things like weapons and
vehicles for the US government this is
the heart of that term made famous by
President Dwight Eisenhower the
military-industrial complex those at the
heart of the military-industrial complex
are making themselves are being made
official parts of trumps administration
not only is it a clear conflict of
interest which is par for the course
with Trump par for the course has a
whole new meaning actually now that we
know that how much Donald Trump is
playing golf it's almost funny to use
that term par for the course when
talking about Trump I wonder how good he
is I golf it doesn't strike me as much
of a golfer I heard he's terrible yeah I
heard is terrible we've got Ivanka in
the White House we've got the Exxon CEO
and friend of Russia Rex Tillerson in
the State Department and the White House
announced just a couple of days ago that
Donald Trump is appointed let's just go
through the list Benjamin Cassidy is now
the Secretary of legislative affairs at
the State Department Cassidy was a
senior executive at Boeing recipient of
huge big league government contracts
Donald Trump has named Jonathan wrath
Hoss Hoffman as the Department of
Homeland Security's Assistant Secretary
of Public Affairs where did he
previously work the Chertoff group
that's the homeland security consulting
firm connected by the way to Michael
Chertoff Bush administration official
responsible for getting the Department
of Homeland Security to put in those
really expensive porno scanners that the
TSA uses in airports Pat Shanahan has
been a while since I said porno scanners
i sometimes i crack myself up Pat
Shanahan was appointed by Donald Trump
as Deputy Secretary of Defense Shanahan
was a vice president at Boeing who ran
none other than the company's missile
building division a business executive
with no government or military
experience
the nominee for Trump's Deputy Secretary
of DHS is Elayne Duke who consulted for
a number of defense contractors
including the Columbia group with
manufacturers these things called
unmanned drones and then you have
Heather Wilson who's been nominated to
be the head of the Air Force a former
Lockheed Martin consultant she was in
charge of maintaining Lockheed's 2.4
billion dollar a year contract to build
and research nuclear weapons and keep
the contract close to competition this
is just a sampling there's actually a
minimum of 15 officials with financial
ties to defense contractors who have now
either been nominated or appointed by
Trump to some of these positions in
Washington some people might not realize
that Secretary of Defense mattis and
Secretary of Homeland Security Kelly who
were primarily paid by defense firms
they're back right you know Madison's
associated with the military but also
someone who was paid by defense firms
before joining their cabinet-level
positions so I don't know what it means
to drain the swamp pad but i'm pretty
sure that this isn't draining the swamp
it's a revolving door it sure is I mean
I think most Trump supporters look the
other way though they think well there's
not politicians in these major roles now
it's people like the finance ears the
oil tycoons of people who actually are
in the military industrial complex so
they see that as an improvement Trump is
actually calling for a budget that would
make perfect sense if you're filling the
swamp with these types of people Trump
is calling 454 billion dollars in added
military spending next year a 30 billion
dollar budget increase for the DoD and
DHS for this fiscal year and guess what
roughly half of that 30 billion is
planned to be spent on new military
equipment Trump was going to drain the
swamp crack down on the lobbyists not
only isn't he doing that the lobbyists
are joining government uh I I would love
to just have a trumpet call in and
explain to me how this resolve the
revolving doors is revolved
so fast that it's flying off of its
hinges and the swamp is overflowing with
the lobbyists Trump said wouldn't be
part of his administration you can
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com /re
DDI t next the conclusion to my
interview with the great lawrence krauss
today's sponsor is movement watches at
mvmt watches calm / Pakman I've been
wearing a movement watch for several
months now as you can see here and
people love it everywhere I go it
attracts attention and people say that's
a really cool clean looking watch what
kind of watch is that and very often the
next question is how much does it cost
and that actually relates to the two
broke college kid that started movement
watches they would go to department
stores and see watch as they liked and
then realize the price tags were upwards
of four or five hundred dollars not
really affordable so they created a
watch line in movement watches which not
only has the great designs that they
liked and wanted but the watch it
started just 95 bucks because they sell
online they cut out the middle people
and are able to sell watches starting at
just $95 and for viewers and listeners
of the David Pakman show you can go to
mvmt watches calm / Pakman that will get
you fifteen percent off the watch of
your choice plus free shipping and free
returns okay so once again mvmt watches
calm / Pakman free shipping free returns
and fifteen percent off the watch of
your choice